we finish each other's sandwiches you do
realize this is recorded in your line
now we're talking I am Kristen Bell and
I am friends with Josh GAD I think no
you should know that it can actually be
proven in a court of law if it comes to
that friendship does not belong in a
court of law
that's life in 2020 girl I'm Josh GAD
amongst other things I'm friends with
Kristen Bell and now we are here to take
BuzzFeed's quiz a bestfriends quiz a
bestfriends quiz I don't need to test it
I know already you know either no one
can know one can test our friendship Joe
except they're BuzzFeed which is about
to check off every detail you get
correct about your best friend okay
Kristen you go first what's my birthday
February 23rd you looked it up on the
Internet I literally saw you look it up
on the internet because I did the same
thing miss July 18th
they can't test us if we're in we're at
home well you can test me because my
internet is really shaky but you're
Kristen Bell I'm not allowed to have
internet you know taxes again state yeah
you said he's against it we're trying to
stay off the grid so we both got our
birthdays correct it doesn't matter that
we cheated that's an easy Google your
astrological sign cancer yes correct
let's see you're not a Capricorn you're
the second one no you're the third one
you tell me you tell me it's your
birthday well you're wrong I'm not the
third one and it's Isis I'm a Pisces
I'm the finished it's not the third once
you were wrong Pisces number two No then
I said Pisces because listen to me Josh
Capricorn is technically the first one
cuz it rolls right through January you
do realize this is recorded in your line
that like they can use this no somebody
call the moon because listen my husband
is a Capricorn and he's January 2nd I
think like Aquarius is technically the
first this is the dawning
[Music]
no because Capricorn rolls from December
to Jan and then if we roll so it starts
in December if anything if it starts in
December my daughter's birthday is in
December it's not like a lowly birthday
into January she's not I don't like it
when you corner me what I will say is I
was thinking of Capricorn as the number
one mm-hmm Aquarius is the number two
the certain the number three one which I
don't know the name of mm-hmm thanks
that's correct
your middle name I want to say Sheila
incorrect Kristin Sheila Bell my middle
name is Anne your middle name you looked
it up
no I didn't I'm gonna guess Rockefeller
nope [ __ ] Sheila I'm Joshua I got my
middle name is actually along it's
either lon Joshua Ilan dad this next one
you should know because you saved my
parents during a hurricane do you
remember their names or were you just
like mr. and mrs. GAD first of all I was
always like mr. and mrs. GAD because
that is how I roll
well thank you their names are Sam and
Susan yes you look that up no maybe my
pet my my parents names are salmon Susan
my biological father's name say my
stepdad is named Stan that's one that
you met and my mother is Susan and the
internet really did help you except I
didn't cheat on this one I just happen
to know that your parents are Donald and
an Amber down good old Don and ambi no
first of all depends on how many parents
you've on a name I've had a few you know
K I'm some Lorelai Tom Kelly John
another John do you understand the
definition of parents yeah there are
people who helped raise you and love you
gentlemen I just love to be loose
definiton I have a lot of people who
love me I wouldn't say that they're my
parents but if we're talking sperm and
ovum yeah talking Tom and Lori that's
look that's who I would have guessed do
you think I have brothers or sisters
I think you have a sister okay in
harmony you're you're wrong it's not
harmony because I don't have a sister
I led you astray intentionally sublime
you and only child no I have two
brothers my were Jason Jeffrey and Josh
I was supposed to be the sister I was
supposed to be Jenny what I was thinking
of you're single you're single child
depends on how you look at it I can't
take these loose definitions anymore I
don't know how to answer these questions
with very sort of I play life fast and
loose you can't there's nothing you
could Google or quiz that would that
what I'm outside the box
okay I can't be defined okay Cherie does
Christian Bell have siblings let's see
what she says
would you like to meet Sarah JT and John
because you clearly don't have a memory
of them you have a big family
yeah I know that's Megan my dad is one
of 12 okay
there's 57 or so cousin and then there's
like into the 70s of great-grandkids K
we Pro we are like rabbits we're like
Jackrabbits K they're from Ohio there's
a lot of my parents were married and I'm
the only child from that marriage my dad
then married Kelly who's been my stepmom
since I was three and she brought in
Jodi and Sarah who are not Jodi and
Sarah Bell
they have different last name of their
mother and then my mom when she married
ray there's four on that side hmm are
you gonna update Siri tonight yeah I'm
I'm all over my Wikipedia page there's a
ton of tea by the way I'm gonna give
myself credit for getting them right
because I we got them write the name of
your Clint pet you I'm sure you have a
pet you have two girls you don't know if
I have pets you seem like like a loving
caring go deeper I hit you up for money
for my animal rescue stuff but yeah I
have an unfortunate amount of pets how
many pets do you have I have three dogs
two of them that are on death's door and
having nothing to do with Korona they're
just old I've got a soft spot for senior
dogs so we got a lot of dogs
I was on your property and I never saw a
dog so I just I couldn't remember they
sleep all day but then we got a new one
named Frank and he's a real little
all right well do you think I have a I
know you have a beautiful little dog and
I want to say her name is Z's didi didi
your all-time favorite business hmm
I shake nervous cuz I mean we've
discussed is probably so many times I'm
gonna say Little Mermaid yeah it's a
it's a tie between Little Mermaid in the
Latin for me but I think I would I
Michael a little more me but because I
love Sebastian so much your favorite
all-time Disney movie you know like a
minute ago I fully just forgot we were
like on camera doing a quiz and I
thought you just saw you just thought
that we were talking with nobody
watching BuzzFeed likes to lull you into
like feeling safe in Aladdin you're
right yeah take the credit your favorite
Broadway musical obviously I know that
it's the Book of Mormon did you see me
in Book of Mormon I did I did I did I
was gonna say I just missed you but I
did I saw you and Andrew I know your
favorite show cuz you're very public
about it it's Hamilton it's not my
favorite show but I do love Hamilton
like with every bone in my body my
favorite show is way more obscure and
it's Stephen Sondheim's A Little Night
Music and we do that together can we do
a little music I would love to oh my god
I can't so beautiful I can't get enough
of it what is your favorite all-time
musical I'm Guiness wow I don't know
your hand it was announced as a motion
picture remake today today again my
internet is very spotty well then I'll
tell you just think June June June no
end just all you is there a Jew a Jewish
musical but it's not Oliver I'll tell
you that
Fiddler on the Roof oh of course
last TV show that you binge watch the
good place that's what you're putting at
me no no something else from my resume
actually last one i binge know was the
crown this is a three the last one you
binge watched Central Park well that's
true well but you know that because you
sent me the links doesn't matter all
right no wait
I know what I look for your biggest
celebrity crush lin-manuel Miranda you
knew that well you put I mean you put a
picture of him on you like that sort of
like that big giveaway yeah sure look
I'm trying not to be too thirsty okay
just between us I'd yeah I just want you
know what I want him to be is in charge
of everything I want him to just write
my obituary and I want it to be just
beautiful I want you to just be like a
flower in poetry your celebrity crush is
I have no idea where to start maybe I'm
gonna go based off of if I'm looking at
your wife as a type Salma Hayek nope
like actually way off
oh no but I kind of has like a like a
sultry like dark haired olive skin it's
eita but [ __ ] but Ida does too
either has a sultry that would be the
equivalent of me calling your husband
dicks you know how many people call him
Zach's please tell Zach's I said hi Evan
Rachel Wood I have the biggest question
I could I could never admit that Earth
but she was a coaster but I just think
she's so good well she knows now he
knows she knows he's not another time
BuzzFeed yeah she's just she she like
makes my heart flutter she's so
beautiful
yeah she really at that face man whoo
all right I didn't get any of those
what's okay your least favorite food I'm
gonna say
pickles no I like pickles each other I
don't love like to sweet pickles but I
like pickles a lot and my least favorite
food is like liver I hate anything shinu
I don't like like food that's why you
can't count that one like what about
something that people actually eat
nobody like no way I mean as you can
tell I'm pretty much a go for mostly
anything you don't like spicy very much
do you how do you leave meeting is there
a button Buick spicy Joe I'm Nate I was
one of the best contestants hot wings
has ever had I love spicy to the degree
where I actually think Dax and I Zacks
you know my husband we've killed our
taste buds I think they're dead
I take it back you love spicy food what
is your least favorite oh oh I don't
like goat cheese coffee order I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say you drink black coffee
you know that because I've discussed it
on your husband's podcast I did full
disclosure
didn't listen to it that's the sign of a
real pet of a friend right there that's
a real real he goes to work he talks
then he comes home he talks I gotta
listen to that's my that's a lot of
talking you like something
iced you like a little bit of sweetness
not too much not excessive you don't
like sweet I don't like sweet I don't
like sweet drinks at ah let me finish
you like something sweet to look at not
to drink you like something that's like
hey look sweet are usually like a matcha
mmm not just good your morning tea
drinker now we're talking if I could
hook up iced green tea right here all
day I would your favorite alcoholic
drink like it's a made-up drink it's not
even a drink most people have heard
before it's like something like the
shitty Papa it's like something that you
came up with a buttery nipple yeah it's
you like a good vodka I feel like
we're really embarrassing ourselves when
we're like I love Josh I love Kristin
we're great friends and then we truly
just don't know the facts it's a little
quiz about what you know about each
other it's a quiz about like why won't
you invite me over to your home to
record my voice on your husband's
podcast you know why you're never
available Josh because you're always
working but I like the stuff you put out
so I let you work I just want to be
really clear I let you work okay I don't
drink
I have never drink but I did write
that's why I don't know what the hell
you drink I drink they gave my 20s like
normal time and then I was just like why
do I have a headache for 72 hours after
I have it okay that's why so I stopped
for like 15 years then last July someone
poured me a glass of rose a and I have
been drinking Rose a but it's it's very
new to me because I'm I'm just literally
I'm like the person who I can't get on
the internet I just discovered Rosie
like so lame but I I do like Rosanna if
I had to say what my favorite drink
would be it would be that because it's
the only drink I'm really familiar with
what do I drink yes I think you drink
Jack and Coke a high school senior
Prince Jack and Coke that's the most
offensive thing you've ever said to me
well you know why my husband is sober
and when he talks about his glory days
when he was really being crazy talks
about jacking a chocolate martini no
good whiskey I like like I do like the
occasional like jalapeno kind of
flavored margarita like I do like I do
like that kind of thing your favourite
swearword nipple Clint I can't decide so
that's incorrect all of them your
favorite swear word is shart no biggie
your go-to karaoke song blame it on the
ring it's just guessing anybody's ever
said about me I actually go really crazy
hi
so my go-to karaoke song is
I should have known that because you've
done that before what's mine I don't do
karaoke I mean I've been karaoke before
but it's never something I really got
into so I wouldn't even know if I had to
I'd ask politely if they had a musical
theater section and probably ask another
person to do for good from wicked
because I knew you I hope you get that
wrong I hope you're like agent is
calling everyday it might be too old no
I don't think we did well oh I got 15
out of 15 you checked all of them yeah
I'm an honest individual I checked six
on the list you know a lot about your
best friend you've been friends for a
while now and you know all of the basics
and then some you can't wait to become
even closer as the years go on mine says
you know absolutely everything there is
to know about your best friend you've
been in each other's lives for a long
time now and you even finish each
other's sentences you're basically the
same person we finish each other's
sandwiches we have been in each other's
lives for over ten years you've seen me
through I met you in college that's 20
years so don't watch on Apple TV plus
check it out eating is one of the most
fun things I've never done in my life I
don't know if six out of 15 is good
enough for me I'm gonna be researching
you all night you know you should
research listen to your husband's
podcast very literally talk about my
entire list